If you checked all three of them, you're
exactly on the right track. Let's talk about
it. First of all, you know that with
this, with the naive implementation there is going to
be too much contention for the lock when
the lock is released. Because everybody, both t2
and t3 in the previous example, jumped in
and started looking at the test and set instruction,
trying to acquire the lock. And there are thousands
of processes, everybody is going to be executing this
test and set instruction, so there is going to
be plenty of contention on the network, in order to
get to that shared variable, that's the first problem.
Now, let's talk abolut why the second answer is
also the right answer. You know from the previous
lesson that a shared memory multiprocessor has private caches associated
with every one of the processors. And it is
often the case that the caches may be kept
coherent by the hardware. Now if the private caches
associated with every processor and if a value from
memory can be cached in that, there is an
issue with test and set instruction. And that is,
test and set instruction cannot use the cached value,
because it has to make sure that the memory
value is modified atomically when, when it is inspecting
the memory. And therefore. By definition, a test and set
of instruction, is not going to exploit caches, it is
going to bypass the cache and go to memory, in
order to do the test and set operation. And therefore
yes, this is also true, that the spin algorithm that
I gave you, spin on test and set, is not
going to be able to exploit the caches. The third
problem is, is the fact that it might disrupt
useful work. And it's also a good answer and
the reason is because, when a processor releases the
lock. After releasing the lock, that processor wants to
go on and do some useful work. And similarly.
If, let's say there are four processors trying to
acquire the lock. Only one of them is going
to get it, and the others are going to have to
back off, because they're not going to have the lock.
Now the one, one guy that did get the
lock has useful work to do. But, because of
the fact that there's a lot of contention, the
guy that can actually do useful work is being
impeded from doing useful work because the contention that
is there. In all the other processors trying to
go and get the lock when it is not available.
So, this is really the problem, that the test
and set instructions, because it is bypassing the caches,
it's first of all causing a lot of contention
on the network and it is also impeding some
of the useful processor from carrying on with its
work. Which may advance the cause of the parallel
program. So all of these are good answers in
terms of the problems with this, with this naive spinlock.